hello everybody my name is markiplier
and I'm here with Jack say hi my arms in
my armpits that's okay
did you know that good as a whole fan
base dedicated to like my arms and my
pit hair well you do have nice arms
I do have nice arms they're very veiny
just not right now but usually like when
I'm in periods of high stress and I've
really been cranking my fingers I
usually get pretty veiny in my hands
I'll tell you about other places that I
get veiny jack start the game everyone's
looking at this and talking about my
veins alright fine it's gonna be a
podcast yep pretty much well I mean
that's what this was last time it was
just kind of a podcast everyone was just
hanging around we were just telling
[ __ ] stories no wait we were telling
[ __ ] about you and your stupid clash of
clans addiction oh yeah that's right I
was playing clash of clans way back when
I actually I'm supposed to because I got
OH some of my extended family does play
shout out to Mike who plays clash of
clans oh my yeah he's like he's my step
he's my like double stepbrother now
which is it's a strange situation cuz my
stepmom like wow there's food here oh
you're not in the game yet oh we're a
minute into this like let's play and I'm
already confused by so many things oh
sorry
you're not even loaded up yet well I
mean what people didn't know is that
there was like 10 10 or so new
improvements that were made
since the game was released a while ago
improvements busy don't talk about it
for this is a good game or it was
actually is yeah
surprising woman and oh there you are
look at my hair how's it going
you're not as iris as I thought you'd be
now what about you are you are a
dark-skinned man oh oh are you okay
alright wait I don't want to be
offensive here Irish meeting a
dark-skinned - that's not what I'm
saying you you don't look like Jack is
what I'm going for you yeah yeah and you
have far less hair than regular marriage
hey don't be offensive just because we
feel equally challenged people don't
have hair doesn't mean that you can yell
at us hey you've lovely great hair thank
you I know I do you sponsored by lorry
oh why Lord why do you mention lore'l
specifically because it could have been
absolutely anything I don't know but I
usually get some berries and I'm already
dying really we just our objective here
is not to die as early as we do in the
other games can I throw myself off this
cliff and end the horror of what this
let's play is gonna be before it starts
hey you're nice it doesn't matter if
you're nice I just worry about if you're
good at this game or not I don't think
anybody's good at this game yet well
it's kind of been out for a few years
now so if someone's got to be good at
the tennis ball you okay over there the
ball I'll fetch it okay oh wait oh how
do we do the walkie talkie again I think
we have a walkie talkie yeah Oh
inventory Sam are we gonna shout the
attack you q how everybody it's not
echoing septuple Oh doesn't echo anymore
hello my neck oh it doesn't
maybe we're not in the right channel
maybe we get how do we I don't know
well um we have no idea island goers it
was weird that it was like a megaphone
before so I guess there's maybe there's
a megaphone item that we can find out
later and then hopefully oh I found a
selfie stick
you did well it's a guy's head on a
spike with him Cameron that's really
clever
also this head is gigantic did whoa why
did you pick up that body I know we're
going to do some surgery I do go through
the table go let me sniff your butthole
he vanished I don't see you sniffing
anything I see you messing with that
table you get a buddy I picked up the
same body that you picked up it's just
okay let's just take our friends my name
is Ted okay
yours is Liam bill Steve bill bill and
Ted get it oh yeah yeah exactly
we're gonna have an excellent adventure
with dead Bill and Ted oh boy anyway
what is there to do with this game well
I mean it's everything to do with this
game like the last time we played we
were just trying to survive and now
we're trying to play oh man I've still
got my walkie-talkie out so this if this
is actually shouting out to any natives
we're gonna be in trouble
obviously it is oh where is he where'd
you go it fall out my name oh there's
your name yeah I pretty I'd be pretty
sure that they'd have some questions
about us carrying their dead friends
bring bringing them back is that what it
is like like the actual lore of this
game is that be alien mutant creatures
are the dead brought back to life or are
they just living that are actually
turned into zombies aliens aliens you
want to explain the multi lagged
multi-armed crazy thing they're mutants
that's what I was asking whether they
were aliens or mutants
I don't know there's some HP Lovecraft
[ __ ] going on anyway
probably they said they added more like
I'm I'm legitimately saying that in the
last few updates like there's been a lot
of updates and obviously it looks a
little better because now we're in unity
5 8 there is a lot more content added to
the game and it runs better - does it
well mine's that like 60 ok good for you
where'd you go again right here you all
over there damn it
you're just so well camouflaged with
your bandages and white shirt look I'm a
tree oh my god you pop another there's a
rainbow where oh my god there is go on
make the joke what make rainbows there's
only one I know pots gold leprechauns no
to be honest I really wasn't even
thinking that like I totally have
matured past the point of making fun of
your spoon raisins I just think you
haven't played I mean now that we've met
in person you know I I feel like I've
grown as a person to not mock you for
your disability of being hybrid sorry
sorry sorry to all my Irish fans out
there of which I have none left
well you did forget her to do my accents
though that's good yeah I don't know
what happened there like I forgot to do
your accent I forgot how to do yamimash
his accent I just failing as a person in
general
you're just failing at life thank you
thank you very much Jack your words that
mean so much to me so so what are we
doing I don't know finding a place to
build our shelter let's do that I'm all
open up the shelter thing and see if
there's new stuff oh yeah what is the
thing for that be me are you wanna be
there's a SAP collector what's a SAP
collector a collector of SAP we can make
a skull lamb
we can make a stick marker animal trap
explosive wire trap advance decorative
skulls deer skin wow there's a lot of
stuff here yeah we can make a rug rug oh
and we make our home for our family that
we're gonna make later yeah it'll be
beautiful
- bald man are gonna make a baby I
didn't see we're gonna make a baby I
just said we were gonna make a family
question
nature nature finds a way there this I
haven't seen the new Jurassic world I
really haven't
oh don't what happened love it [ __ ]
dinosaurs are cool story is oh really
yeah it's so dumb oh poor Chris Pratt I
can't cut down this tree just find a
boat you did where well I found I found
a Z boat oh yeah look at this it looks
like The Cliffs of Moher the cliffs are
who they kiss them over down a County
Clare and Ireland are those like the
cliffs cliffs of cliffs of Dover kinda
are they white
no they're just joint cliffs on the end
they're not white I don't want a part of
it my mind just goes places for
everybody at home we're not trying to be
offensive whatever did you see did you
see why the Sharks touch the shirt he
doesn't do anything for because you
broke him already oh yeah [ __ ] off
seagulls oh they do why do they split
into two we do it for some reason to do
it for the hosts I think Oh nobody else
doesn't do it okay well I'm twisting up
this shark something fierce Oh
poor Joel's so who's gonna go out to the
boat and find the stuff I'm volunteer as
tribute oh he's not dead he's not dying
okay
Oh oh my god you okay jack I can't
understand you with your accent you're
under water ax I can't understand your
accent is there actually anything on the
boat now
is there a phone a carton of milk with a
missing person picture oh no we have to
find out the multi legged mutants uh-huh
okay I found a yacht magazine oh good
for when we get this family and afford
our yacht I can fap to this can you oh
yeah Wow yours do anything so you are
far more skilled than me I have much to
learn about fapping before I thought
it's all about imagination man you make
what you can out of it like cooking
magazines
oh okay explain to me how that happens
well they do use a lot of oil and they
rub like chicken breasts keep going keep
going I want you to really really really
evolve this idea that you're going you
know when you get a nice pink juicy
chicken breast and spread oil all over
and you just slap it and it just makes
that man bright in the comments below
what you're fapping noise is so we can
all share way too much about each other
just just a lovely person just great
commentary quality commentary right
there wait you're making fun of my
commentary here yeah you're making fun
of my fab noises or just my commentary
just your comment ok good my fab noise
is totally fine your v noises are
glorious yeah exactly
well you know after three years of doing
Let's Plays I'm just trying to phone it
in as much as possible this last few
years you know yep I don't know we just
become parodies of ourselves after a
while that's very true
I mean I compare it to like TV shows
where the characters like in the office
like originally they were just boring
office workers but then they have to
develop their characters so much to the
point where they're literally making fun
of who they are in the beginning of yeah
yeah like who is it who what's the name
of the big character the big dumb one Oh
like half bald guys yeah yeah Kevin what
is his name
Kevin Kevin is it Kevin yeah okay I want
to make sure it was actually covered
yeah but in the beginning he wasn't like
super dumb he didn't even Hawk the same
way that he did before and all sudden
over the seasons he just got dumber and
dumber and yeah he's like the Hulk now
yeah Kevin spies I'm not I'm not sure
you've seen the office I I have no idea
I have yeah I still haven't watched the
like final season of it no wait I
haven't like watched every season of it
or anything I've watched like episodes
okay
enough to know what it's about yeah true
enough anyway it's time to in the
episode cool huh yeah we did a lot in
this one well sure howdy we sure did so
thank you everybody for joining us we're
gonna keep doing a bunch of [ __ ] do
you wanna say anything I hope you had
fun you don't hate that's all we can
know for please please don't hate us if
you do write in the comments all right
all right thanks again everybody as
always we'll see you in the next one
Oh swing